marine le pen est l'invitée de preuves
par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
votre sort dans cette campagne divise
les sondeurs et les analystes marine le
pen en effet ce que vous serez terrassé
par jean luc mélenchon ou bien est-ce
que vous sauverez votre troisième
position les paris sont ouverts
d'ailleurs vous lancez vous même à paris
aux instituts de sondage on y reviendra
plus tard mais il arrive que les
chiffres vous met en joie j'imagine je
veux parler de l'étude csa indiquant que
vous êtes en tête chez les 18 24 ans oui
je n'ai remarqué déjà pendant cette
campagne a énormément de jeunes dans nos
meetings beaucoup de contacts par mail
il ya effectivement incontestablement
une vague chez les primo votants chez
chez les jeunes c'est très
enthousiasmant ça parce que être la
candidate des jeunes c'est évidemment
aussi de la candidate de l'avenir alors
ce qui laissait lui manifestement c'est
ce que vous dites sur sur l'immigration
notamment et puis vous l'avez vu il vous
jugent moins extrémiste que votre père
ils ont raison je crois surtout quand
ils sont ils sont parfaitement
conscients que le modèle qui nous est
imposée depuis 30 ans est un modèle qui
nous mène à la ruine
ils sont attachés à leur identité ils
ont envie à nouveau d'être fiers d'être
français d'être fier tourne vers vous
parce que quand la hausse et dans un
pays aussi il vous trouve moins
extrémiste que jean marie le pen je sais
pas parce qu'ils ont qu'est ce qu'ils
connaissent tellement de jean marie le
pen celle qui ont 18 ans envoyé ils n'en
connaissent peut-être que ce qu'on leur
a dit en l'occurrence de jean marie le
pen même il ya quelque chose
effectivement qui se passe nous avons
des préoccupations communes et ils sont
par ce vote en train de construire leur
avenir c'est ça qui est vraiment très
intéressant alors l'avenir tel que vous
le voyez pour la france vous en parlerez
dans un instant avec les familles comme
si de l' agence france-presse
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindra pour la fin de cette
émission la religion pas toutes les
religions vous l'avez rappelé occupe une
bonne place dans votre campagne je
parlais de l'islamisation de la france
que vous dénoncez marine le pen mais
c'est l'archevêque de paris monseigneur
vingt-trois qui ce week-end estimait que
l'on fait une place disproportionnée à
vos phrases alors ce n'est pas
l'excommunication mais c'est le voeu de
silence
oui mais les gentils monseigneur
vingt-trois qui s'occupe de ses moyens
et puis moi je vais m'occuper de
politique parce que il ya la loi de 1905
qui fait que en règle générale on rend à
césar ce qui est à césar et à dieu ce
qui est à dieu donc qu'il s'occupait il
a déjà beaucoup de travail à remplir ses
églises
quant à moi je continuerai à oeuvrer
pour le bien du peuple français et à
défendre même si ça lui ça lui déplaît
les racines effectivement chrétiennes de
la france parce que je pense que c'est
ce qui constitue aussi notre notre adn
notre identité la manière dont nous
voyons les relations humaines notre
vision
mais apparemment l'homme à ce qui
chagrine le cardinal archevêque de paris
c'est ce que vous dites donc sur la
religion
vous vous trompez apparemment d'ennemis
l'islam c'est une des grandes religions
monothéistes
ce ne sont pas les fanatiques qui disent
s'en inspirer mais est ce que vous vous
tromper d'ennemi
mais qui a dit ça qui est acquis c'est
monsieur monseigneur vingt-trois qui dit
ça j'ai obtenu il défend en tous les cas
le respect dû à toutes les religions et
joyon l'a pas attendu si vous voulez
nettement pour respecter toutes les
religions moi je suis je défends la
liberté de culte parce que je suis
attachée à tous les acquis qui sont ceux
de mon pays mais qui sont aussi des
acquis qui viennent de l'histoire nous
avons eu des guerres de religion dans
notre pays nous avons tant de conscience
collective et parce que nous avons cela
notre conscience collective
nous sommes très attentifs à ce que la
religion ne déborde pas dans l'espace
prix public il serait bien de s'en
rappeler d'ailleurs en l'occurrence mans
je ne combat pas l'islam mais retenue
comme un musulman qui s'ils se sentent
stigmatisés pourrait se tourner par
exemple vers des personnes comme tariq
ramadan bien monsieur la stigmatisation
c'est l'espèce de deux méthodes qui est
utilisé depuis des années des années
pour empêcher de régler les vrais
problèmes et d'en parler moi j'ai dit
très clairement je ne mélange pas
l'islam et le fondamentalisme islamique
je combattrai pied à pied le
fondamentalisme islamique pied à pied
parce qu'il est contraire à nos valeurs
parce que la charia dont il veut faire
la promotion est profondément contraire
à la démocratie et aux droits de l'homme
tels que je les défends que
c'est la charia est profondément
réductrice des droits que nous avons
nous à qui tout au long de notre
histoire et qui forgent de notre
civilisation
je n'ai encore une fois rien contre
l'islam est prêt et même je vais vous
dire je défends les musulmans qui sont
eux-mêmes victimes de la pression que
fait peser sur eux le fondamentalisme
islamique
je les défends et ils doivent venir à
mes côtés parce qu'avec moi ils sont
sûrs de ne pas être obligé de main de
maître à voile à leurs filles de se
faire attaquer parce qu'ils font pas le
raz le ramadan ou je ne sais quelle
qu'elle soit pensée de l'appel à la
résistance le mot était utilisé par
l'intellectuel suisse et égyptienne
tariq ramadan ce week-end au congrès de
lui au 9 mai monsieur ramadan je le
considère comme étant un homme assez
dangereux en réalité parce que il la
double langage voilà il est ils
représentent les frères musulmans vous
savez que il est un descendant du
fondateur des frères musulmans or les
frères musulmans sont dans le monde
derrière toutes les revendications
fondamentalistes ils sont derrière
toutes les avancées de l'islamisme le
plus radical le plus brutal et par
conséquent je n'ai pas que monsieur oui
il a incontestablement un double
discours parce que c'est un homme
intelligent et il sait très bien ce
qu'il faut dire dans les assemblées
lorsqu'il est sur territoire français
mais l'on sait également qui sont ses
amis donc dix mois qui sont tes amis et
je te dirai qui tu es nicolas sarkozy
s'est rendu à drancy aujourd'hui une
première visite du président candidat en
banlieue
durant cette campagne il a rencontré des
responsables religieux locaux et puis il
a vanté la réussite de son plan de
rénovation urbaine rappelant qu'il avait
investi 43 milliards d'euros pour lutter
contre les guerres qu est-ce que c'est
également un bilan que vous partagez que
sarkozy est un faiseur de coûts on le
voit d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai parlé de la
viande halal il a fait un coup en allant
arracher sly comme monsieur hollande
passe sa vie dans les banlieues
il fait un coup en allant banlieue
d'ailleurs tout le monde passait bien
banlieue ben moi je ne vais pas en
banlieue parce que d'abord je vais en
campagnes voyez-vous parce que l'immense
majorité de la france elle vit dans la
ruralité
elle vit pas dans les banlieues unis
dans les quartiers les quartiers et les
banlieues ils ont tous ils ont les
caméras de télévision ils ont l'argent
de la politique de la ville qui se
déverse sont des milliards
ils ont achevé de leurs préoccupations
les responsables politiques en
permanence surtout pendant les élections
yaka malheur c'est que les gens qui
vivent en banlieue et qui sont
confrontés aux difficultés ils savent
qu'ils n'ont rien attendre de nicolas
sarkozy ni de françois hollande
ils savent que moi je veux peut-être pas
pour aller les caresser dans le sens du
poil pendant les élections mais qu'en
revanche le seul projet véritablement
capable de les arracher à l'insécurité
qu'ils vivent à à l'absence de
perspectives professionnelles à
l'inquiétude qu'ils ont à l'égard de
leurs enfants
c'est le mien eva joly était à
hénin-beaumont aujourd'hui là où vous
vous entendez bien vous présenter aux
élections législatives n'est ce pas
marine le pen alors il vous a qualifié
d' héritière d'une fortune il légitime
la succession lambert est ce que vous
allez la poursuivre pour diffamation
comme votre père d'ailleurs à qui elle
avait reproché la torture en algérie
oui bah elle c'est à dire qu'elle dit
femmes c'est pas très joli de la part
d'une ancienne juge d'instruction
et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs une
circonstance aggravante qu'elle soit
ancienne juge d'instruction pour
prononcer des propos qui sont aussi
gravement diffamatoires
elle aura évidemment à en répondre
devant les tribunaux mais surtout ce qui
est amusant c'est que elle est allée à
hénin-beaumont dit non mais marine le
pen n'a rien fait contre la corruption
alors madame joly elle n'a jamais rien
fait que d'être confortablement installé
dans un fauteuil de juge d'instruction
quelle horreur elle a eu face à elle des
des gens extrêmement poli dans des
grandes affaires financières
c'est terrible elle a dû beaucoup
souffrir mais moi je suis allé sur le
terrain pour lutter contre la corruption
avec steeve briois
nous on est allé arracher les
informations dans une mairie pour
montrer à la population qu'ils étaient
en train de se faire voler et on a
obtenu l'incarcération du maire d'hénin
beaumont
alors quand madame eva joly aura sur le
plan politique fait autant que ce que
j'ai fait en matière de dénonciation de
l'ensemble des réseaux de corruption qui
pourrissent le pas-de-calais elle pourra
venir donner des leçons de sape de sa
chaise de juge
est-ce que vous l'imaginez demain
ministre de la justice de françois
hollande puisque manifestement cesson
l'ambition à elle de plus en plus
affiché l'ambition l'ambition il est
joli ce gouvernement 1
madame eva geôliers à la justice
monsieur mélenchon il va et où parce que
lui aussi il a beaucoup d'ambition
chacune d'elles a dit qu'il ne voulait
pas entrer au gouvernement de françois
hollande oui bien sûr le croyez part
bien sûr c'est ce qu'on dit avant les
élections blé goudé voilà ça prouve mais
très bien je veux dire cette révélation
des ambitions des uns et des autres
démontre une chose très claire c'est
qu'en réalité
tous ces candidats sont ce que j'appelle
des faux candidats ils ne sont pas là
pour gagner appliquer leurs idées ils
sont là pour batailler pour un poste de
ministre pour quelques circonscriptions
législatives c'est ce qui fait que je
suis radicalement différente de dans
cette campagne puisque je moi je suis là
pour gagner et je n'ai rien à vendre et
on ne peut pas m'acheter et je
n'accepterai aucun poste d'aucune forme
que ce soit je lutterai pour défendre
les français et pas pour défendre mon
intérêt personnel à propos de jean-luc
mélenchon vous avez déclaré qu'il était
l'idiot utile de nicolas sarkozy car il
affaiblit françois hollande sauf votre
respect marine le pen est ce que vous
êtes l'idiote utile de françois hollande
puisque vous affaiblissez nicolas
sarkozy non la différence c'est que
monsieur mélenchon ils attaquent marine
le pen c'est quand même étonnant parce
qu'après tout cet homme qui est censé
être révolutionnaire pourrait avoir un
comportement une posture révolutionnaire
dans cette action qu'est ce qu'il ya de
révolutionnaire
attaquez marine le pen tout le monde le
fait
demande le fait depuis des années et des
années le système entier madame parisot
attaque marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon
et marine le pen la cgt attac marine le
pen
eva joly attaque marine le pen nathalie
kosciusko morizet attaque marine le pen
ça ne fait rien ça vous donne est le
problème ça n'a rien de révolutionnaire
la réalité c'est que comme il participe
du système eh bien il fait ce que font
tous les gens qui participent du système
il cherche en réalité à taper sur le
seul candidat qui n'est pas dans ce
système est que tous ensemble
en réalité ils craignent le plus la
preuve il a dit que son ambition ultime
c'était de passer devant moi il est déçu
mais bon vous n'avez aucun doute sur la
syrie je vais vous parler du pape
maintenant je vous ai parlé de
monseigneur vingt-trois tout à l'heure
un le pape qui a rappelé dans son
message de pâques ce week-end et il
fallait que le plan de paix
international se met en place en syrie
manifestement ça n'est pas encore le cas
comment est-ce que vous réagissez face à
cette surenchère meurtrière encore une
cinquantaine de victimes
aujourd'hui en syrie on ne vous a pas
entendu dénoncer le régime bachar al
assad non musulmans les dénonciations si
vous voulez vous pouvez prendre tous les
gens tout le monde l'a dénoncé en
faisant la guerre c'est mal c'est pas
bien mais la guerre c'est pas bien la
pluie c'est désagréable
les morts c'est affreux mais mince a les
mains sales de sybille cette atroce
il ya rien de plus facile que de faire
ça c'est pas de la politique ça
n'importe qui est capable de vous dire
ça on est très honnêtement y compris
d'ailleurs vont ces candidats y compris
les candidats à l'élection de miss
france voyelles vous disent aussi que la
guerre c'est mal et qu'elles sont pour
la paix dans le monde
bien quand on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
mais vous de la situation alors que les
cas vous vous prendrez votre propos sur
la responsabilité de ce qui se passe
concrètement vous trouvez j'ai fais une
responsable politique je suis pas
candidate à l'élection de miss france
donc j'essaye de faire preuve en même
temps d'intelligence de hauteur de vue
aussi parce que mattia international sa
a bien manqué anouk dirigeants français
dernièrement je vous rappelle quand même
le l'échec absolu de l'intervention en
libye tout de même parce qu'on n'en a
pas beaucoup parlé de cet échec et des
conséquences
de l'arrivée au pouvoir des djihadistes
avec notre argent avec notre aide
avec notre armée dont la première
décision a été de mettre en oeuvre la
charia et puis qui a contaminé en
quelque sorte
l'ensemble de ses voisins et qui est
aujourd'hui à l'origine du mali qui est
aujourd'hui à l'origine la syrie mais
permettez moi de terminer ma phrase qui
est aujourd'hui à l'origine de la
déstabilisation très grave du mali dont
les deux tiers du territoire sont pris
en main par des fondamentalistes
islamiques probablement d'ailleurs qui
ont avancé grâce aux aaa des armes
françaises c'est quand même pas rien
comme catastrophe en termes de résultats
bon la syrie est telle dans la même
situation on peut se poser la question
on peut seul oui on peut se poser la
question par conséquent je suis
complètement convaincu de la nécessité
de trouver par la diplomatie
une sortie de crise ne respecte pas sa
parole et je les sais je crois que
monsieur kofi annan et - comment dire
sûr que cela que vouloir il attend quand
même que son plan si la raison il le
reconnaît qu'il ya des mouvements de
troupe et qu'il peut y avoir des
déplacements de leurs yeux une avancée
mais je crois qu'il faut qu'avec
l'ensemble des nations qui sont soit des
nations amies de la syrie soit des
nations qui ne sont pas pouvoir trouver
une sortie diplomatique car on ne
gagnera strictement rien à faire en
syrie
ce qu'on a fait en libye sauf des
centaines de milliers d'immigrés
supplémentaires parce que c'est
aujourd'hui évidemment ces conflits
entraîne une fuite de population qui
vient évidemment vers l'europe alors on
va accueillir dans un instant samir
tounsi donc de l' agence france-presse
marine le pen avant cela voyons comment
les sondeurs que vous accusez de faire
des coûts relève le défi que vous leur
avez lancé un sont-ils prêts donc à
parier un mois de salaire par points
d'écart entre votre score réel et celui
qu'il vous attribue
non qu'il attribuait la semaine dernière
parce que je range généralement
s'approche de l'élection pure on ouvre
le parapluie quand vous donne un point
de plus ce matin reportage de jérôme
rabier les paris sont ouverts mais pas
un seul institut de sondage ne compte se
prêter au jeu des pronostics lancé par
la présidente du front national pour les
instituts croire que son décès prévoir
c'est se tromper sur la nature même de
leur métier les attentions europe ont
pas vocation à être des outils de
prévision
on cherche à comprendre on cherche à
mesurer on cherche à avoir les
évolutions on essaye d'approcher la
vérité avec nos moyens c'est une science
sociale c'est pas une science dure
évalué selon les instituts entre 13 et
17 % le vote le pen reste tout de même
historiquement à un niveau élevé mesure
est d'autant plus facilement que la
parole sur ce sujet c'est maintenant
libérés ont dit de plus en plus
fortement et fréquemment je vote en
faveur de marine le pen et on reconnaît
de plus en plus facilement on avoue
pourrait-on presque dire que dans le
passé on a voté front national on a donc
des échantillons au poids nous ce qui
permet de ne pas beaucoup redressées
marine le pen à vouloir se dédiaboliser
le fn c'est finalement banaliser le vote
le pen est désormais calculée comme pour
n'importe quel candidat avec des
corrections bien plus infimes
qu'autrefois
ce qui finalement ne lui plaît pas à
leur marine le pen s'indigne elle combat
les sondages les élites les
éditorialistes finalement tous ceux qui
ne la vois pas gagner mais tout cela
sonne un peu comme un vieux couple et ce
défi aux sondeurs son père lui même
l'avait lancé son père il ya quelques
vingt ans je crois et fait un pari avec
michel brûlé fondateur de bv a
exactement la même nature un pari
financier valoir me jean marie le pen
avait perdu son pari et messieurs le
projet et verser cet argent est une
association humanitaire
donc rien de nouveau sur le soleil de
saint cloud quand les sondages en début
d'année la place et comme une postulante
crédible au deuxième tour personne
n'entende et marine le pen s'indigner
dont les instituts on en plaisante
presque quand la mesure n'est pas bonne
c'est l'instrument qui est critiquée
jamais la stratégie adoptée
voilà ça me retombe ci est avec nous
bonsoir samir vos questions à marine le
pen sont ni chainel boursière marine le
pen joue pas l'intérêt d'un reportage
c'est que celui là ça apporte quoi comme
information à part distillé quelques
petites piques aux donateurs louis sont
de nouvelles excuses et de faire des
coups d'être mettant des premiers à me
moi qui a accusé sans leur faire des
coups tout le monde à clé vous renvoie
la balle
en dix ans on fait passer un tel devant
fait passer le devant et c'est à vous le
savez bien c'est quand même pas une
nouveauté bon non non non je ne peux pas
confirmer ce que vous faites ici je ne
sais pas ce que vous dites qu'elle va on
fait passer les comme ça c'est comme une
cause de petits chevaux pour qu'elles
pour que dans quel but de vendre du
papier ça marche assez bien d'ailleurs
il faut bien le dire
voilà mais c'était le cas en 2002 déjà
je vous rappelle que l'aigle arlette
laguiller était présenté comme le
troisième homme le 23-24 marche
d'ailleurs elle passait devant de jean
marie le pen elle a fini à cinq et demi
jean marie le pen à 17
bon ben ça c'est encore mais les
sondeurs ne se sont jamais trompés un
jeu je vous rassure moi ce que
j'aimerais si vous voulez pour faire
avancer ce débat parce que mon objectif
n'est pas de critiquer les sondages de
manière gratuite c'est peut-être
d'imposer aux sondeurs parce qu'on ne
peut pas en même temps donné comme ça
vendre en quelque sorte un dd des
sondages et en même temps dire ah oui
mais c'est c'est pas du tout une
prédiction
et bien si ça n'est pas une prédiction à
ce moment-là qu'il donne des fourchettes
je pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
visible beaucoup plus compréhensible ça
éviterait aussi un certain nombre de
coups médiatiques et ça permettrait à
chacun d'eux d'avoir effectivement une
vision à peu près précise à peu près à
ce que c'est comme si point la précision
trois de plus trois de moins ça fait
quand même large mais je trouve que ce
serait plus juste plus honnête à l'égard
de ceux qui lisent justement ces
sondages mais peut-être que du coup ils
les vendrait moins familier vous êtes à
combien
selon vous je serai à combien je pense
que je suis au dessus d'un vous êtes
parti d'un qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça devant c'est exactement ça monsieur
c'est exactement ça est ce que vous
savez quand on fait de la politique et
les journalistes devraient avoir cet
instinct l'a d'ailleurs quand on fait de
la politique on s'aperçoit effectivement
d'un certain nombre de sensations ou de
terrain de une énergie
et un enthousiasme le les nombres les
mails que l'on reçoit les oui tout ça ça
participe de l'instinct politique qui
fait qu'un certain nombre de
responsables de l'ump disent d'ailleurs
régulièrement que marine le pen est
probablement au dessus de ce que disent
les sondages parce qu'eux aussi ils ont
un instant z c'est pas réservé
uniquement à ma famille politique d un
jeune actif il y en a partout
les loyers au second tour je pense que
ce sera extrêmement serré et que
l'hypothèse de ma présence au second
tour reste une hypothèse crédible
je veux revenir sur un sondage qui vous
est favorable vous êtes en tête chez les
18 24 ans
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur proposer
j'ai rencontré des militants du fnj
récemment en picardie il rame comme ils
disent pour trouver le moindre stage
quelle est la réponse concrète que vous
leur apportez à ces jeunes qui sont
prêtes à vous faire confiance alors vous
voyez c'est étonnant parce qu'on m'a dit
on m'a reproché aux usa mais vous vous
adressez pas aux jeunes mais alors vous
vous adressez pas favori qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous n'aurez guère un
problème très concret lis mon avis ces
professionnels qui cherchent un stage il
ya des problèmes et je vois pas dans
votre discours via des solutions quand
visuellement portez vous avez une
manière communautariste d'envisager la
politique ça vous pensez qu'il faut
sectorisé la politique je joue nous
sommes nés mais permettez genre à
laisser mois terminés nous sommes un
peuple et c'est ça que ces jeunes ont
compris
nous sommes un peuple nous venons d'une
histoire nous avons un avenir à
construire et il participe pleinement de
cette construction
vous avez une vision de la politique est
celle d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre de
responsables politiques qui fait qu'ils
ne répondent pas aux grandes aspirations
du peuple français
parce que ils ont une vision un comment
dire qu'ils essayent de répondre à un
égoïsme qui n'existe pas il décède bien
mais en réalité les français ne
s'intéressent qu'à eux mêmes alors les
bouchers s'intéressent uniquement aux
cas déboucher les jeunes ne
s'intéressent qu'aux problématiques des
jeunes les personnes âgées ne
s'intéresse qu'à leur épargne et à
l'insécurité et bien ceci est faux les
jeunes ils s'intéressent à ce qu'ils
sont à ce qu'ils vont devenir
il s'intéresse à la persistance de leur
identité il s'intéresse aussi aux
valeurs qui sont les maintenant sur les
stages moi j'ai proposé une chose très
claire
j'ai proposé qu'on arrête de laisser aux
gamins le soin de trouver leur stage
tout seul parce que je trouve qu'il ya
rien de plus terrifiant que cela il ya
des gens aujourd'hui qui ont des
connaissances qui ont des réseaux par
leur faim
bon on peut pas leur reprocher mais en
revanche en a qui ne connaissent
personne
et bien cela se retrouve avec des sages
de moins bonne qualité et ses stages de
moins bonne qualité et bien ils les
suivent en quelque sorte toute leur
scolarité
alors j'ai dit que c'est à l'école dans
ces conditions-là de récupérer les
propositions de stages et de les
accorder par tirage au sort aux enfants
ce qui évitera que les enfants de chefs
d'entreprises de journalistes et
énormément de facilité à trouver un
stage de qualité et que les enfants de
pêcheurs de paysans et d'ouvriers est
beaucoup plus de difficultés parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le réseau social en
quelque sorte pour pouvoir se trouver un
stage de de qualité pendant une question
politique vous êtes persuadé que nicolas
sarkozy va être battu est ce que vous
êtes persuadé que vous auriez un espace
politique plus important sous une
présidence de françois hollande c'est
pas le problème de la présidence de
veolia de questions sur la question de
la présidence de françois hollande
persuadé que nicolas sarkozy sera battue
c'est ce que pense votre père oui je
crois qu'il sera battu
je crois qu'il sera battu parce que
quand il a lassé doivent encore une fois
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça sachant
qu'il progresse
il revient il semble revenir en force
dans les rues ils semblent c'est bien
c'est bien dans le semble que tous ont
monté le baquet de lille oui la vague
bleue mais aussi ils sont là bas moi
aussi je la sens bien monté oui
effectivement je ne sais pas s'ils ont
nettement il a eu raison d'utiliser
cette formulation bon jeu très
sincèrement il a tellement déçu les
français ils ont ressenti cette trahison
tellement dure rarement parce qu'en même
temps il y avait vraiment une espérance
dans son mandat
il y avait vraiment une espérance que je
vais partager à nouveau à ce point non
mais nous en parler avec tellement guemo
l'oms des cas elles aussi non monsieur
si c'est votre question est grotesque et
non mais bon la hausse espère à vous
vous amuser mais on l'a senti cette
dynamique
moi je verrais oui oui mais mais mais
évidemment enfin il aurait fallu être
sourd aveugle où vivent dans une grotte
permettez moi en 2007 bon l faut pas
être très instinctif là pour avoir ce
ressenti qu'il y avait une vraie
dynamique d'ailleurs nicolas sakozy
pourquoi parce que et une dynamique tel
d'ailleurs qu' il pouvait tout faire il
pouvait tout changer et c'est bien là
qu'est la mesure de la déception c'est
que les français n'ont pas compris
pourquoi alors qu'il avait une telle
dynamique et un tel taux de confiance
dans les promesses qu'il avait pu faire
eh bien il les a toutes trahi les unes
après les autres
donc je pense qu'il n'a aucune chance de
gagner et c'est lui qui a dit que s'il
ne gagnait pas il arrêtait la politique
c'est lui qui l'a dit ça veut dire que
par conséquent il va abandonner ses
troupes
il va laisser un champ de ruines et là
vous avez un espace politique et c'est
pas près de l'espace politique c'est que
ça va entraîner une recomposition totale
de galles est votre rôle dans cette
danse memorial d'accès d'imposer la
vraie fracture qui traversent notre pays
qui n'est plus la fracture gauche-droite
qui est la fracture nationaux
mondialiste qui est la fracture entre
ceux qui croient encore en la france et
là il ya des gens de droits des gens de
gauche des gens du centre même des gens
de l'extrême gauche et les gens qui ne
croient plus en la france c'est à dire
qu'ils sont perdus dans un rêve
européiste qu'il poursuivre indéfiniment
depuis maintenant 25 ans avec les
résultats qu'on connaît
en attendant il y a un match dans le
match dans cette élection front contre
front front de gauche contre front
national et des électeurs peuvent se
dire finalement voté marine le pen ne
sert à rien puisque de toute façon on
appellera elle n'appellera pas à voter
nicolas sarkozy au second tour alors que
voter mélenchon est une façon de faire
pression sur françois hollande 7
ça va être la démarche de demande de
nombreux électeurs ah bon bah oui il ya
aussi nombreux électeurs n'ont pas du
tout envie de rentrer dans ce système là
et qui considèrent que le simple fait
que monsieur mélenchon appelle à voter
pour françois hollande démontre qu'il
est en réalité le gros sénateurs
bourgeois qui n'a jamais cessé d'être et
que
n'est absolument pas révolutionnaire
qu'il est en réalité complètement
intégré au système est d'ailleurs c'est
si vrai que il est alter mondialistes
dont il est pour une autre
mondialisation bas le système aussi il
est pour la mondialisation il est inique
ratio nist alors que la première qui
demande de l'immigration c'est madame
parisot du medef qui pleure en
permanence pour avoir plus d'immigration
mais monsieur mélenchon lui en propose
plein la régularisation de tous les sans
papiers etc etc
ça c'est bien quelque chose très
révélateur qu'il appartient au système
et puis encore une fois il utilise toute
son énergie à taper sur marine le pen
qui quoi qu'on en pense n'a aucune
responsabilité dans le chômage la
précarité l'insécurité le pouvoir des
banques etc
c'est monsieur hollande qui a une
responsabilité c'est monsieur sarkozy
qu'elle reste on a vidé et c'est
monsieur mélenchon qui lorsqu'il était
ministre de monsieur j'ose pas un
ministre d'ailleurs comme le dit
monsieur gré m particulièrement soumis à
monsieur jospin
eh bien il n'a pas démissionné de son
poste le ministre quand monsieur jospin
avec a assigné l'augmentation de la
retraite à 67 ans avec comment dire
barcelone lorsque il ce gouvernement à
privatiser plus que n'importe quel autre
gouvernement y compris de droite
lorsqu'il a été décidé la libéralisation
des services publics at il à ce point
changé décidément tout le monde change
la candidate des petits c'est vous on
vous entend depuis plusieurs jours sur
sur ce thème là d'ailleurs ça rappelle
un peu votre père en 56 avec avec
poujade c'est votre conception de la
lutte des classes
les petits contre les gros c'est très
simple tout le monde peut comprendre
mais la société française n'est pas un
tantinet plus complexe que cela
aujourd'hui enfin des jeux permettez moi
je vous avez le droit de me traiter de
simpliste c'est votre opinion mais je
crois que mon projet est beaucoup plus
fin et beaucoup plus approfondie que
celui là ce qui est sûr en revanche
c'est que dernièrement et l on peut s'en
apercevoir dans tous les domaines à
chaque fois que nicolas sarkozy a eu à
prendre une décision la décision s'est
prise au bénéfice des grandes structures
et au détriment de ce que j'appelle les
indépendants ans je crois que les
indépendants dans notre pays c'est ça
qui fait vivre la france
il participe de l'identité de la france
ça a été vrai avec la grande
distribution
autorisé à venir s'installer dans les
centres villes évidemment au détriment
des petits commerçants qui aujourd'hui
ferment les uns après les autres ça a
été vrai au niveau évidemment des
banques
ça a été vrai au niveau des pharmacies
ou nicolas sarkozy a cherché à imposer
la puissance des réseaux de pharmacie
liés à des grands laboratoires contre
les pharmaciens indépendants
il a fait ça aussi avec les taxis au
début de son mandat donc il a fait c'est
que la fnsea où il pousse à la
concentration des grands groupes plutôt
que au sauvetage des exploitations
familiales il fait sec la pêche où on a
un avantage les grands armements au
détriment de la pêche traditionnelle
donc il ya comme un jour être compétitif
c'est dans la logique économique
actuelle hype williams à l'heure c'est
qu'on n'est pas compétitif et plus on
fait des concentrations et moi on est
compétitif c'est donc que ça ne
fonctionne pas donc les remèdes ultra
libéraux ne fonctionne pas mais ça c'est
quand même un fil conducteur de l'action
de nicolas sarkozy qu'on ne peut pas
contester
j'en avais dit oui plein mais perd il a
tort voilà vous venez de donner une
conférence de presse devant la presse
étrangère sur la question de la sortie
de l'euro vous avez répété que vous
étiez l'ennemi juré de l'euro vous
soumet trier cette question de sortie de
l'euro un référendum imaginez que vous
leperlier ce référendum est juste vous
n'avez plus de colonne politique pour
gouverner
non pas du tout tu as en total désaccord
avec vous parce que encore une fois j'ai
toute une série d'autres propositions
qui de toute façon améliorerons la
situation économique de notre pays
mais je dis aux français et il s'en
apercevront très vite je suis pas très
inquiète là-dessus dès qu'il y aura un
véritable débat dans notre pays sur
l'euro et qui ne sera pas une succession
d'anathème et d' insultes parce que pour
l'instant le débat sur l'euro s'est
limitée à des anathèmes on est
on critique l'euro on est fous on est
inconscient on est inconsistant et c'est
avec ces irresponsables et dangereux il
responsable dans ce contexte économique
le dise vous voulez oui que la banque la
banque de france prête à l'état un taux
de 0% d'ailleurs comme jean luc
mélenchon un nom en tous les cas c'est
une proposition non qui n est pas une
proposition de jean luc mélenchon qui je
lui ai entendu le le dire mais non mais
non monsieur
mais audi dans tous les cas votre propre
risque c'est bientôt reviendrai ce que
vous dites est important donc c'est des
prêts à taux zéro de la banque de france
on sait que ça revient à faire
fonctionner la machine à vivre mais que
fait l'union avec ma passion mais que
fait l'union européenne dit moi que
l'inflation de pid et à bien sûr avec en
s'éjectant 1000 milliards d'euros depuis
décembre en âge et en mille milliards
d'euros elle a injecté la bce avec la
planche à billets y a pas eu d'inflation
alors ce qui est bon donc pour la b ce
ne serait pas bon pour la france
alors ça fait quand même des siècles que
nous avons fait cela ça ne fait que
depuis 1973 que nous avons interdiction
de faire et que nous avons donné un
monopole aux marchés financiers
merci pour eux ils nous remercient bien
on leur a versé 1400 milliards d'euros
d'intérêts sur 1700 milliards de dollars
si samir perrine tarneaud donc va nous
rejoindre maintenant avant ce détour par
la psychologie sur les biens marine
mesures visent à ce que révèle votre
parcours votre voix beau geste et je
vous ai vu d'ailleurs l'autre jour vous
emparer du point de la semaine dernière
le diagnostic des psys et vous éclaire
et vous écriez nous sommes donc tous
fous tous n'ont pas tous le thème tran
huy a rencontré la sémiologue mariette
darrigrand qui capte les signes que vous
envoyez existe et il fallait un
personnage à marine le pen et je crois
qu'elle avait aussi quelque chose qui
était en gros la colère incarner la
colère de là
mère de famille on s'est fait une soirée
pizza avec mes enfants samedi soir eh
bien nous avons commandé cinq pizzas
j'en ai eu pour 80 euros près de 530
francs est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de ce que ça représente
il me semble que cette posture de cette
incarnation de la mère de famille en
colère qu'on voit dans les séries télé
cimb éthique que l'on peut repérer qui
était originale qu'elle est une sorte de
création personnelle elle l'a perdue et
on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui du fait
de la montée de jean-luc mélenchon et
bien elle elle recolle à cette image
l'année comme lui une sorte de tribun
avec les grands mots classique de la
rhétorique tribunicienne oui mes amis
j'entends être la candidate de l'ordre
républicain contre l'anarchie
la candidate des principes fondamentaux
de l'état nation contre le désordre
planétaire du mondialisme la candidate
de la république contre la barbarie et
du coup on retrouve jean marie le pen et
et ça fait un peu désuet enfin l'humour
en particulier 7
cette alliance d'un certain humour et de
et de mots du vocabulaire un peu élevés
ou pseudo élevé auxerre j'entends ici et
là le petit clapot des commentateurs
patentés savez la variable murmure des
petits marquis repliés dans leur
quartier cossu bien à l'abri ou du moins
le croit-il
alors il ya quelque chose là qui se voit
c'est 10 en l'absence de plaisir
l'absence de jubilation ça se voit
d'autant plus que jean luc mélenchon lui
au contraire
grand sourire tout va très très bien et
c est aujourd'hui ça n'est pas marine le
pen ça ne pas du tout marine le pen
alors qu'à un moment donné par exemple
quand elle avait chanté quand elle quand
elle rit elle a un rire qui est souvent
repris par par les médias est bien là
tout ça a disparu tout ça est gommé et
c'est un peu morne pour elle aujourd'hui
on voit bien que elle se fait
déstabiliser à la fois sur sa sur sa
droite de républicaine par un nicolas
sarkozy et sur sa gauche populiste par
mélenchon
donc elle elle emprunte à ces deux types
de codes sur un plan purement
sémiologique mais lorsqu'elle est
déstabilisé finalement elle est moins
bonne respectivement que chacun des deux
donc ça veut dire qu'elle n'a pas sa
propre vision
perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint oui
c'est la psychologie c'est intéressant
mais quand il s'applique à soi même
c'est pas toujours agréables on sait
c'est que juste pitoyable enfin je veux
dire c'est comment parler pour ne rien
dire
cellule c'est d'un nul mais alors gérard
marie le pen vous la trouvez mordre
votre campagne comme le d-imager trouve
juste rouge fait une très belle campagne
elle parle d'absence de plaisir elle
vous retrouve pas dans cette campagne un
cantal vous ne la connais pas enfin de
bâtir un avis annexion d'avis sanaa au
crâne on va travailler avoue on n'a
aucun intérêt
finalement c'est votre première campagne
présidentielle à l'écouté c'est une
campagne qui est extraordinaire il ya un
monde fou il faut qu'elles viennent
cette dame là qu'elle sorte de son divan
et qu'elles viennent regarder les yeux
des gens d'accord cette espérance en un
changement
cette cet amour quand on parle de la
france qui transparaissent que ça
transparaît l'amour qu'est ce qui vous
donne cette certaine gravité dont elle
parlait mais évidemment parce que ce
sont des sujets graves parce que raoul
follereau disons peut pas être heureux
tout seul je veux dire qu'on peut pas
être heureux quand les camps les siens
sont malheureux moi mon peuple c'est le
sait ce sont les miens c'est mon peuple
si les malheureux je suis malheureuse et
si on leur a ici on le fait souffrir
je parle avec gravité et même parfois je
suis capable de parler brutalité de ceux
qui le font souffrir mais les jeux j'ai
tellement de cette tellement cette
conviction ancrée en moi tellement ce
sentiment ancré en moi que quand elle
raconta où elle prend pas plaisir elle
prend alain le prend à l'autre vous
croyez très honnêtement que pour parler
de sujets aussi fondamentaux que ce dont
je parle dans cette campagne je regarde
les ce que dit ou ce que la manière dont
se comportent monsieur mélenchon ou
monsieur sarkozy mais enfin il fallait
bien qu'elle faut bien qu'elles servent
à quelque chose mais mon jeu franchement
je chacun sa fonction mais malgré tout
c'est donc votre première campagne
présidentielle en tant que candidat de
vous la trouvez plus dur que prévu
non je la trouve pas particulièrement
plus dur que prévu
pas particulièrement ce qui est dur
c'est que je les conseille à très
longtemps par l'effet du calendrier si
vous voulez j'ai commencé en septembre
la compétition interne janvier ça a été
le congrès quasiment la campagne a
commencé à ce moment là il ya eu
immédiatement les cantonales et puis
immédiatement la campagne ça fait
presque je sais pas plus de 18 mois que
je suis en campagne donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez long en le plan physique
et c'est vrai mais ce qui n'est pas
déstabilisant est-ce que vous avez été
la surprise de la précampagne et puis
après c'est jean luc mélenchon qu'est
devenue la surprise de la campagne
des stylistes entame et non sur bayrou
était la surprise wood décembre monsieur
mélenchon a été la surprise du mois de
mars
encore une fois dans les campagnes de
2007 dans les campagnes de 2002 ça a été
exactement la même chose ce débat du
troisième homme ça agite beaucoup les
médias on adore ça mais j'ai jamais eu
et j'ai jamais été inquiétés si vous
voulez ne serait ce que parce que en
réalité jean luc mélenchon il fait le
plein des voix d'extrême gauche s'est il
fait il fera demain il fera je voudrais
c'est encore le doigt oui oui c'est le
cas il fera l'addition de ce que faisait
lors des dernières élections
présidentielles elle au npa
le pc les verts eelv est l'intérêt pour
vous de la part des médias parce que
vous changez aussi l'image du front
national vous étiez une nouvelle figure
est ce que finalement cette dédié à ce
qu'on appelait la dédiabolisation du
front national ça ne vous a pas
banaliser j'ai pas du tout ce sentiment
là non je vois justement des jeunes qui
sont très fiers de dire qu' ils votent
pour marine le pen je vois les candidats
qui font campagne sauf quand ils sont
attaqués violemment par le front de
gauche de manière normale et moi je me
félicite je me félicite de cela non il
est vrai que le la manière dont les
médias m'ont traitée au cours de cette
campagne radicalement changé aqua part à
compter du moment où il ya eu une prise
de conscience que je pouvais accéder au
second tour là incontestablement les
choses se sont tendues c'est un fait si
vous voulez nous l'avons tous ressenti
comme cela bon c'est en général quand ça
ce temps c'est plutôt vous êtes une un
sujet d'inquiétude c'est plutôt bon
aujourd'hui vous vous sentez les
candidats puissent par filiation ou par
ambition personnelle a sûrement pas par
ambition personnelle je n'ai aucune
ambition personnelle c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui était marqué par financions dans
l'express non pas par filiation
je suis candidate parce que j'appartiens
au peuple français et que je ne suis pas
capable d'être spectateur de son malheur
voilà je ne sais pas faire je ne sais
pas ne pas m'engager dans une bataille
qui me tient à coeur est entendu que je
pense que le temps n'est peut-être pas
si élastique que cela et je suis
consciente qu'il ya des choses qui sont
décidés aujourd'hui
et qui peuvent avoir un caractère
irréversible c'est quoi votre moteur
marine le pen le profond sentiment
d'injustice que j'ai à l'égard de la
manière dont on traite les uns et les
autres c'est ça montre dans sa mémoire
sans qu'il vous faut toujours un ennemi
enfin ça a toujours été mon moteur
le la justice et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'étais devenu avocat
parce que l'injustice mecs aide elle
mais elle est deux de l'énergie en
quelque sorte dans mon moteur deux
petites questions d'actualité d'abord
votre réaction à la pétition qui circule
contre günter grass vous savez
l'écrivain allemand et prix nobel de
littérature il a critiqué la politique
d'israël vis-à-vis de l'iran
or un poème dans un poème qu'il a écrit
récemment il ya une pétition d'écrivains
qui circule contre lui qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
il a écrit qu'il serait il menacé selon
lui la paix mondiale avec son arsenal ou
ailleurs où il faut je trouve et où je
trouve incroyable s'ils voulaient que
des écrivains des écrivains y aussi le
spd qui est le principal d'un mail de
position en allemand et non mais ils se
tirent refuse sa présence dans des
meetings en attendait ça c'est autre
chose qu'aider écrivain celui qu'il
fasse une pétition contre un autre
écrivain paul empêché d'écrire ce qu'il
pense à me paraît ahurissant moi je
croyais que les écrivains étaient pour
la liberté d'expression
maintenant que israël n'ai pas envie de
le recevoir sur leur territoire comme je
crois que c'est le cas ils ont le droit
ça me paraît tout à fait légitime
un état a le droit de décider qui entre
sur son territoire ou qu'il n'a pas
envie de voir sur son territoire ça me
choque pas même cette pétition
d'écrivains ma part et le spd le parti
allemand qui veut pas le recevoir
montpellier qui font si c'est la liberté
de chacun de recevoir ou de ne pas
recevoir les gens mais c'est aussi sa
liberté d'exprimer sa pensée
même si elle dérange et d'une autre
question d'actualité alors que voilà
vous êtes dans votre programme pour la
suppression des nouveaux radars
automatiques pour l'amnistié routière
est ce que vous n'avez pas envie de
rajouter la fin de la limitation de
vitesse
non mais j'ai fait l'obligation du port
de la ceinture
non je pense que
quand on sait qu'on aministie des gens
qui ont volé des vieilles dames qui ont
brutalisé qui ont des gravir l'amnistié
alors donc les automobilistes seraient
les seuls en quelque sorte à ne pas être
amnistié moment des présidentielles du
tout il n'y a pas d'amnistié du tout
vous est chaude ce que vous dites là
écoutez il n'y a pas d' amnistie dans la
dans la foulée de l'élection pour les
délinquants que vous aimez évidemment
monsieur qu'est d amnistie bien sûr tous
les chaque élection présidentielle il y
en a même tous les 14 juillet je vous
signale et mais les automobilistes ne
serait pas amnistier c'est quand même
pas tout à fait normal je trouve ce sont
les vaches à lait se sont devenus des
vaches à lait les radars que la baisse
du nombre de morts qui est quand même
considérable sur les routes à la dame
justifient jusqu'à sûrement la mesure
bien sûr mais la pensée unique va nous
imposer de penser que ce sont ces
mesures là qui ont entraîné la baisse
des ventes moi je conteste cela je
conteste cela c'est surtout je vais vous
dire l'amélioration des de la sécurité
des véhicules et notamment grâce aux
contrôles obligatoires et grâce à la
technologie nouvelle qui a été
développée qui ont permis de sauver
beaucoup de vies
il ya d'autres moyens de sauver des vies
mettre des éclairages sur un certain
nombre de routes améliorée des ronds
points qui sont des ronds-points où il y
à des accidents de manière régulière
mais en réalité on s'aperçoit une chose
c'est que les automobilistes sont
utilisés pour faire rentrer des sous
dans les caisses et pas du tout pour
lutter contre l'insécurité routière que
je combats comme tout grand verglas il
ya un domaine dans lequel vous n'aurez
qu'à mais pas plus de sécurité plus
d'autorité un de ces vérités c'est la
circulation routière cause c'est
systématiquement sur eux que ça tombe
bien ça tombe un peu sur les autres
c'est j'ai relevé une phrase de votre
rival malheureux pour la présidence du
front national candidat aux législatives
dans le var bruno gollnisch une phrase
rapportée dans le monde ce week-end ça
ne sert à rien de faire huer la presse
il faut la massacrer samedi où l'offre
est coûteuse ce pauvre dans quelles
conditions
tout à l'heure qu'il était scandalisé
par cet article parce que c'était une
conversation d'un quart d'heure plus tôt
sur un ton badin avec les journalistes
or je ne suis absolument pas dans vous
savez dans quel contexte il a dit ça sur
un quai de gare figurez-vous cédé 2,91
gagner j'en avais sur lequel kopeck des
complexes et panneaux quel endroit c'est
un moule à massacrer ok donc ont tenté
de fermer à présent au meeting
mais je fais pas eu et dans je ne sais
pas non mais nous faisons pas eu et la
presse dans la musique j'ai toujours dit
d'ailleurs que la presse est essentielle
au fonctionnement démocratique pour tous
qu'elle fasse correctement son boulot
c'est ce qu'on a essayé ce soir là merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent pour un
nouveau preuve par trois avec cécile
duflot ce sera demain sur public sénat
bien sûr à 18h bonsoir à tous